hey folks if you'd like to support me or
this channel move university in creating
more video tutorials then please
consider making a financial contribution
at my website booth university calm
thanks and enjoy the video okay in this
video I want to talk about free fatty
acids and a little bit about their
nomenclature and conventions typical
conventions now in biochemistry and in
biology we often use what's called the
common names which I will abbreviate in
CN or as CN whereas there are also
systematic names which I will abbreviate
SN that are often used in organic
chemistry and that's basically based on
the carboxylic acid naming system so
normally common names are used but
systematic names can be helpful in
understanding what's going on with the
nomenclature and conventions ok let's
start off with our first example if we
have a saturated 18 carbon fatty acid
the convention is 18 : zero so what do
those two numbers tell us the first
number 18 tells us how many carbons are
in the fatty acid chain so it's the
number of carbons the second number what
is the second number tell us the second
number tells us the number of double
bonds specifically the number of
carbon-carbon double bonds right
carbon-carbon because we can't think
about the the the double bond to the
carbon eel double bond right and so this
is saturated so we already knew like
even if they didn't tell us that zero
part we know that it's saturated but if
they didn't tell a saturated 18 carbon
fatty acid we should be able to tell
from 18 : zero that has zero double
bonds four zero carbon-carbon double
bonds then it's a saturated fatty acid
that we think so I've drawn that down
here this is an 18 carbon fatty acid
saturated okay carbons one
now some people whatever reason they
sometimes forget about the carbonyl
carbon as being one of the V carbons in
the chain so that's the first carbon and
it'll be numbered in this way carbon
number 1 2 3 4 5 all the way to 18
okay now this 18 carbon saturated fatty
acid has a name
it's common name is stearic acid or
stearate okay now which of these is
actually correct or completely correct
they're both correct but the the actual
name of this one because it's
deprotonated it's not actually an acid
anymore right it's the conjugate base so
stearic acid would refer to this this
carboxyl group being protonated and
stearate is actually what I've drawn
because it is deprotonated now what is
the systematic name the systematic name
is an octave decanoic acid or an octave
deca no eight okay so what is that
basically telling us well the octa octa
means eight Dec Dec means 10 so that's
where the 18 comes from right 18 carbons
and then the N refers to the fact that
it's basically an alkane right there's
no double bonds so it's the same thing
over here
octa octa Dec can so an 18 carbon alkane
alkane carboxylic acid right so it's
just an alkyl group no double bonds
right all single bonds and the N refers
to normal so that's basically telling
you that you have a straight chain okay
now I'm going to kill these numbers for
a second and talk about these carbons
that I've labeled here the bottom left
I'm pointing to the first carbon carbon
number 1 that is the carbonyl carbon
carbonyl carbon or you can call it the
carboxyl carbon now both are correct
it's a carbonyl because it's a C double
bond o but it's a specific type of
carbonyl because it's involved in the
carboxyl chain or carboxylic acid
functional group or carboxylate since
it's deprotonated so it's also called
the carboxyl carbon and that's probably
more specific and probably more correct
but both are both are not incorrect if
that makes sense
okay so now that we have that that first
carbon the one that's immediately
adjacent to the carbonyl carbon the one
here label with his blue arrow
is the alpha carbon the Greek letter
alpha the next one would be beta and
those are the first two letters of the
Greek alphabet
you could go on further so that the next
one is gamma the next one the one after
that is Delta so on and so forth but
normally we don't really go farther than
alpha or beta and the reason why this is
important one particularly why it's
important is that those this process
called beta oxidation which is the
process that oxidizes the beta carbon
and breaks down fatty acids for energy I
actually have a video describing that I
might put up an annotation here if you
want to watch that video but that's why
understanding the convention is
important now I just I just said of this
you could call this the Alpha Beta Gamma
Delta carbons so on and so forth but
like I said normally we don't go further
than beta however if we go to the very
end of a chain so in this case it would
be the 18th carbon right the very end of
the chain that last carbon some hat
sometimes doesn't has a name or has a
convention and that carbon is is called
the Omega carbon Omega looks like a
little W that is the Greek letter Omega
and Omega is the last letter in the
Greek alphabet so here it's the last
carbon in the fatty acid chain so that
is the Omega carbon why is that
important well let's look at this here a
little clinical correlate here this is
representative of some fatty acid where
we have a carbonyl carbon and then this
here I put a parentheses around the
second carbon and then put N because it
can be however many carbons long but
we're mainly going to think about the
last carbons the carbons at the end of
the chain that last one will be the
Omega carbon and if we start the
numbering at that that last carbon at
the Omega carbon we call that carbon
carbon number one we can't call it
carbon number one because we saw that
the carbonyl carbon is actually number
one so what we can do is we can call
that carbon Omega one and then start the
numbering from there so we'll get Omega
1 Omega 2 Omega 3 Omega 4 and if we have
a double bond between car
Omega 3 and Omega 4 we have what's
called an omega-3 fatty acid and some of
you might have heard of those they are
often talked about as being pretty
important or in helping to reduce the
risk of heart disease and so some people
will actually take fish oil as a
supplement or they'll take omega-3 fatty
acids as supplements and to sort of help
with reducing the risk of heart disease
two examples are acaso Penton pentanoic
acid and hexane in oeq acid those are
two examples and I think those are
prevalent fish oils so if you ever
wondered why people take them as a
supplement it's because they there's
there are indications that these things
help reducing the risk of heart disease
now that I'm not over here trying to
give you advice on taking supplements
I'm just looking at this purely
academically if you're interested in
supplementation and you're concerned at
all there's probably good questions to
ask your doctor anyway on to the next
one next example we haven't the next
example is an unsaturated 18 carbon
fatty acid okay so 18 : 118 so we have
18 carbons 1 1 carbon-carbon double bond
ok cool now the question is where is
this double bond there are 18 carbons
how do I know which carbons it's between
well I've drawn two things here I've
drawn I've drawn these two fatty acids
and I've drawn the double bond between
carbons 9 and 10 both cases over here
though it was cysts and over here it's
trans so now I'm telling you that I
already knew that the double bond which
was between 9 and 10
but this convention here didn't tell me
that this convention didn't tell me that
it just told me that I have one
carbon-carbon double bond in the chain
by the way that means that I have a move
far right a monounsaturated fatty acid
but I didn't know where the you can't
really know from this convention where
the double bond is so let's look at
these name
see if those tell us anything the common
name or common names oleic acid or ol d8
and of course I've drawn the holy 8 here
right because it's deprotonated but I
still don't know the old aook acid or
olia the common name doesn't tell me
where this double bond is it also
doesn't tell me about the nature of the
double bond is it sis it like it is in
this case or trans in this case how do I
know I don't know
nothing nothing yet has told me what if
I look at the systematic name so the
systematic name says sis
Delta 9 octa decanoic acid or sis Delta
9 octet key no 8 this is where we're
getting get into the good stuff
okay so let's let's talk about the these
stuff that should be pretty clear so
octa Dec that's going to tell us the 18
carbons right so that's something we
already saw in the previous example some
something that's different here though
is that we've got this little een
instead of n instead of Dec can Noack or
deque can oh wait it's dead keen so
that's telling us that we have an alkene
which is a double bond right
carbon-carbon double bond so that's
something new also it's telling us that
we have sis assistant wand so we already
know that this one's not right and we
know that the double bond specifically
is going to be Delta 9 what that means
is that the double bond starts at carbon
number 9 and goes to carbon number 10 so
we have a double bond between carbons 9
and 10 and it's a cyst of a bond so this
is the correct structure okay so this is
only eight or oleic acid or sis Delta
nine oughta Deki no way or octa decanoic
acid or specifically this one right
because deprotonated but notice how I
broke down that name I got the en part I
got an alkene so I got a double bond I
octa Dec 18 carbons Delta 9 the
is starting at carbon number nine and
going to the next carbon carbon number
10 and then sis is telling me that of
the geometry of that the the the double
bond so I know this is the correct
structure that is oleic acid or Olli
eight and notice that it is unsaturated
and it's kinked right it has this little
bend right or kink because of the nature
of system of ons whereas a trans one of
course is straight not something we
talked about in the previous video okay
let's kill these numbers and move on to
the next example next example is an
example is a an unsaturated eighteen
carbon fatty acid so I didn't put
eighteen carbons here it's an
unsaturated fatty acid that is 18 - so
that means we got 18 carbons and we've
got two carbon-carbon double bonds so
I've already drawn it correctly here but
I want to show you this as a further
example that the common names don't tell
us anything about where these double
bonds are right linoleic acid linoleic
the heck that doesn't tell me anything
right where's where's the double bond I
don't know okay I've drawn here the two
double bonds are between carbons nine
and ten and twelve and thirteen okay not
something the systematic name tells us
okay so now there's something a little
bit different about this one in terms of
what it tells us so again octa deck octa
deck 18 carbons now octa deca or octo
deck now we've got here instead of eeen
we've got dying dying so there's two
alkenes right two carbon-carbon double
bonds dying where are they they start at
carbons number nine and start at number
carbons number twelve
so between nine and ten in between 12
and 13 and are they
sister trans sis sis systematic names
are wonderful they tell you every single
bit of information that you need to know
about it so if you can familiarize
yourself with these systematic names or
at least work through them then drawing
these fatty acids especially if you have
to memorize them
of course you're taking it would make a
lot of sense to to understand systematic
naming to help you draw these and
remember them as opposed to just
memorizing them understand don't
memorize words to live by
anyway so when I drew this I just
started drawing a straight chain a
straight saturated chain but then when I
got to carbon number nine I knew that
I'd have a double on there so I I drew
it straight across right and then I put
the double bond there and then I went
then I continued drawing it as if it was
a saturated fatty acid when I got back
to twelve I drew another double bond and
then do the rest of it as if it were
saturated so after that though I
realized that this is going to cause
some kink action right so we've got a
kink here at this double bond we've got
another kink here okay and so in this
case we've got more than one
carbon-carbon double bond right in this
structure so we've got a PUFA
polyunsaturated fatty acid as opposed to
the monounsaturated fatty acid that we
just drew in example two so I hope that
was helpful
now I do have a list here of some other
some other fatty acids that I encourage
you to draw or try to draw on your own
it could be a good practice so here
we've got 16 0 that's palmitate or n
hexade decay no eight right hexa Dec 16
and alkane right normal straight chain
that one should be pretty easy
palmitoleic 16 1 so it's got one
carbon-carbon double bond it's a syst
double bond starting at carbon number 9
so hexa deck keno 8 the E and of course
alkene linoleic oceany not a little
inally 8 we just drew Canole 8 this is
Lynn Nolen 8 so it's got 18 3 so it's
got three double bonds three
carbon-carbon double bonds and they're
all cysts starting at carbons 9 12 and
15 so between 9 and 10 12 and 13 15 and
16 and notice this Oxitec try no.8 try
I you know eight so three ins three
alkenes Iraq a date 20 carbons zero zero
carbon car double bonds systematic name
n I casa no 8 okay so that I cost that's
that's that's refers to 20 carbons
that's kind of weird but that's what
that refers to this last one here 20 and
for a racket donate it's got all sis
double bonds got four of them so four of
them is tetra tetra bean right and of
course I drew them I wrote them all here
as oh wait Oh 808 Oh 808 and that's
because again most Safari acids
typically exist is in their deprotonated
form so I didn't put the the omec acid
name here just also for the sake of
space but a fun fact is that arachidonic
it is a 20 carbon fatty acid with these
four double bonds and it's a precursor
molecule in synthesizing the eicosanoids
eicosanoids are these 20 carbons
signaling molecules that I may or may
not make a video on anytime soon but
they can be important when you study
signaling pathways anyway I hope that
video was helpful and kind of
understanding what's going on with the
naming and mentions when it comes to
fatty acids and if you have to memorize
any of these for any exam that you're
taking I strongly encourage you to
really think about these systematic
names look them up if you have to and
try practicing just the drawing of them
and hopefully you can sort of remember
how to draw them as opposed to simply
just looking at it memorizing it trying
to draw it over over and over without
thinking really through what's going on
with the name yeah so I hope that video
is helpful thank you for watching yo if
you found that video helpful don't
forget to Like comment subscribe for
more content and if you know anybody who
might find the video is helpful then
please share with them Thanks happy
studying